approximately 2 700 light years away is
Kepler 69c
this super Earth could be around 7
billion years old
this puts it perfectly in the estimated
five to eight billion year old age range
for super habitable planets this range
is based on the three and a half billion
years it took for a complex life to
appear on Earth
so the best chance for finding life
could be on a planet a little older than
us
only this exoplanet could be a little
too big to be super habitable it has a
mass almost four times that of Earth
a rocky planet this big could have a
single colossal continent that would
have huge deserts in its Center
but the coastline Washed by Kepler's
ocean could be your perfect spot to move
to